the Continental Congress had had a
president but the president of the
Continental Congress was an office which
involved little more than serving as the
chairman of the Congress's sessions
several of the state constitutions had
tinkered with the notion of establishing
an executive committee rather than
vesting power in a single individual
like a governor and whatever form a
national executive might take everybody
wanted to avoid going to the other
extreme and resurrecting the idea of a
monarch for America now these concerns
make the executive designed by the
convention all the more surprising
because the new constitution would vest
the entire executive power in a single
person a president who would have
general responsibilities for seeing that
congressional legislation was duly
executed who would be commander in chief
of the Army and Navy and time of war and
who would be the general supervisor of
the Republic's Foreign Relations nothing
like the old chairman of proceedings in
the Confederation Congress furthermore
by passing the jealous interests of the
states the president was to be elected
by the people of the United States as a
whole now this presidency struck many of
the old revolutionaries as the most
objectionable feature of the new
constitution Patrick Henry protested
that the tyranny of Philadelphia may be
like the tyranny of George the third and
that might have been the fishbone that
the states choked on were not for two
concessions that were made first of all
the convention amended the process
whereby the president was elected so
that Americans would not vote directly
for the president and thus put the
states on the shelf but they would vote
indirectly Americans would vote in their
states for state electors who were
supposed to represent the various
candidates for president
these electors would then assemble as a
college not a college as an educational
institution a college in the older sense
of the word which simply means an
assembly the electors would come
together as an electoral college and
then they would cast votes for whichever
candidate they represented whichever
candidate tallied up the most votes in
the electoral college was to be
President in fact that this meant that
while the people voted for the president
it was the states through the state
electors who elected him the other
concession which made the new presidency
more palatable was the unspoken
assumption that George Washington a
figure of universal Trust would be the
president under the new constitution in
fact one thing which made the
Philadelphia Convention as successful as
it was was the fact that Washington was
invited and agreed to become the
chairman of the convention the prospect
of this same man the hero of the
Continental Army
now the successful presiding officer of
the convention the idea that this
Washington would also be as everyone
assumed the first president under the
new constitution did a great deal to
disarm objections to the notion of the
presidency as outlined in the new
document